et bien c'est une histoire fort long
mais qui n'est pas internet et que je
serrais d'exposer d'une manière bien
brève il est certain que dans
l'antiquité
oudéa bien avant l'ère chrétienne il
existait une importante 10 patients
juive il n'y avait pas d'antisémitisme
dans l'empiré romain la position des
juifs étaient bonnes et le judaïsme
n'était considérée comme une religion
honorable de même
il y a eu depuis des temps très reculés
des colonies juives dans l'extrême
orient en inde aux existe encore et
ainsi nous existait encore il ya peu de
temps et là non plus les juifs n'ont
fait que couler non fait call any des
fleuves donc ni de fleuves de sang c'est
dire que
l'antisémitisme
est un phénomène de la civilisation
occidentale
est ce qui se passe et c'est ici que
d'après la conception de l'église
médiévale
les juifs sont le peuple déicide
coupable des plus grands crimes de tous
les temps et en même temps ils sont le
peuple témoin qui doit attester par son
abaissement même de la vérité du
christianisme
donc ils sont soumis à un statut
infamant ils doivent porter la ruelle
ils n'ont pas le droit de posséder la
terre ils sont annoncés des presque de
la plupart de métiers puisque on les
accepte pas dans les corporations
chrétienne et on ne le laisse comme
possibilité que les métiers informant et
notamment le prêt à intérêt pourquoi le
prêt à intérêt parce que d'après le
construction du temps le chrétien qui
prêtent de l'argent à intérêts
forfait son salut éternel donc il vaut
mieux que ce soit le juif qui le fasse
puisque les données de toute manière
dans ces conditions les juifs au moyen
âge dans la mesure où ils ont pu suivre
ce sont en partie spécialisée dans les
activités financières
donc dans ces conditions étant donné ce
qu'on appelait l'enseignement du mépris
par rapport aux juifs de l'église
le populaire les a hissés et en leur
qualité de plater d'argent et en leur
qualité de déicide il s'était entouré
d'un halo de légende
il était censé dégager une odeur
spéciale qui se posaient à l'odeur de
sainteté il était censé tuer les petits
enfants chrétiens profaner les asti
quand il y avait une épidémie c'est que
les juifs avaient empoisonné les puits
ils étaient donc les boucs émissaires
par excellence
et c'est dans ces conditions que
les juifs ont éteint a entouré d'un halo
de suspicion et de haine qui d'une
certaine manière et malgré tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis la laïcisation
l'émancipation a survécu presque jusqu'à
nos jours est la meilleure preuve c'est
ce conte la légende des sages de sion un
de meilleurs outils la propagande
italien
c'est une version à peine laïcisé du
mythe des juifs qui veulent la position
de la chrétienneté
ils étaient les juifs étaient censés
former une société secrète qui trame est
la condition de tous les chrétiens et
qui ambitionnait le pouvoir mondial
et cette légende qui a énormément celui
à la propagande hitlérien a encore est
paru
il ya une quinzaine d'années la plupart
doit s'en souvenir lorsque peu avant la
poire mort de staline on la lance l
histoire du complot sioniste
impérialiste des blouses blanches qui
veulent empoisonné les chefs du
communisme et ainsi de suite
[Musique]